[Music]
dota 2 is a game of complex choices
thanks to the countless interactions
between hero abilities and items now
just one of those abilities can be the
difference between winning and losing a
teamfight
and when it comes to the big leagues
even the pros mess up sometimes so with
the International coming soon we thought
this would be the perfect time to bring
you the top 10 miss plays in dota 2 we
thought we'd kick off our list with a
player that is known for his unfortunate
mishaps paternal Envy squaring off
against PD during a qualifier for the
Boston Major 2016 and be decided that he
tried to solo Roshan he's got a lady
they're going to go right in the roach
after they get this tower there's no way
and it went exactly as you thought Envy
was furiously trying to strike down
roach before the enemy team could rotate
and kill him but with only a sliver of
health left on the roach the last swipe
of his clock killed MV and the enemy
team even got a chance to kill him talk
about a rough day at the office
sometimes in eSports a play is so bad
that it immortalizes the mistake for
years to come
which is why one of Nona's most famous
examples of this comes in at number 9 on
our list during a match between CLG and
m5 during the international two's group
stage m5 s PGG tried to land a black
hole to swing a fight in his team's
favor and well he quite literally missed
everyone pretty decent positioning PGG
fishy for the black hole petty fight it
he has to he doesn't want them he wants
to like another storm he can't get
either nobody
4-cyl ga2 heroes down 4m5 misery for all
the black hole air ball from CVG after
so many good what's first-rate get black
hole gets stolen that's gonna be a team
wipe that's gonna be GG and five all it
from that moment on whiff black holes
would forever be known as a PGG black
hole at the core of most catastrophic
miss plays is simply a lack of
communication and nothing illustrates
that more than our number eight miss
play OG were ganking LF wise batrider a
Zanna popped his omnis legio
his teammates were nearby unfortunately
jure ax was on another page and popped
his eul's to hold the bat writer in
place which canceled out the damage ana
was hoping to deal hey bro - yo
susceptible wait no no no he doesn't
have a dual scepter Oh somebody mess Oh
whose get someone's ghettos that was
either first fuels boy Punk ball and
that dogs all the omnis last all in the
end in flame was able to pop his BKB and
get away safely during a ti5 match
between virtus pro and complexity
swindles taught us an all important
lesson about dropping your items just
don't do it our number 7 miss play is
that fateful moment when swindles
dropped his you'll scepter in an attempt
to eke out a little bit of extra mana to
fight with who are you trying to call
since I think swindle knows just lost
his jewels I think he dropped it to
getting the bride of his bottle in the
bottom Lane oh and got destroyed by the
shaker when he ganked him with the echo
so that's an 2,800 gold loss that
unfortunate play marked the end for
complexity's run at ti5 during the
finals of ESL one Hamburg 2017 secret
had their backs to the wall against
virtus Pro and needed to pull off a big
play to get back in the game so Fatah
had a two man reversed polarity on both
of VPS carries and mid once sent three
remnants to the enemy's location in the
hopes of dishing out huge amounts of
damn
at least that was the plan team secret
losing too many too quickly until I
starts to create more of himself if his
team is dead make a battle of the corn
was but not be cleaned up epicenter does
a great job at that team secret what
actually happened was a bout of
miscommunication that's not Fatah skewer
the enemy stack lid one miss his alt and
their chance at pulling off a comeback
come to a less than dramatic end
everybody knows just how good universe
and evil geniuses were at their peak but
as our number 5 miss play proves even
the mighty are sometimes humbled by some
sloppy play and that's exactly what
happened at 2017 s Kiev major whens I
made this catastrophic blunder on Io as
I used his ultimate to teleport
universe's legion commander in for a
gank attempt which by all accounts is
expert usage of the two heroes Ultimates
that is until zypher got to untether
from universe transporting him back to
his original location and a sudden death
it's not a camera universe
they won't do all this eventually a 30s
[Applause]
huge mistake from sight they're gonna
possibly kill universe now sorry had
some amazing higher plays but just a bit
of a mess cool - to bring universe out
of that og would go on to beat eg - oh
and eliminate them from the major simply
put the ESL one New York qualifiers in
2015 were not kind to funnik he whiffed
on not one long jump most will be pulled
back oh the psycho misses sponeck not to
make him in it's gonna be full committal
here they're gonna jump in in fact
they've actually managed to lock down
PSN meanwhile the black hole gets laid
up and again it only it doesn't catch
anything at all but three enigma all
teased oh he had them the black hole
ready to go but there was no more damage
out now look go to play fun accessible
he's searching for something but again
get it a complain wimp once again Mon
phonic - cost his team a chance to play
on the big stage in the Big Apple team
liquids run at ti7 was a historic moment
for both the organization
and for kuroky but our number-3 misplace
should remind you that things could have
gone differently if it wasn't for a
major blunder from newbie in game number
two
taking on TL in the grand final new VIII
were ahead and making a high ground push
looking to get on the scoreboard but
after a blown KP ultimate things started
to go downhill for the Chinese squad
just chipping away at the Tarrytown miss
Davina
oh he didn't see that my Tama Mahaska
Lincoln for such a big mistake Linkens
sphere gobbled up the ulti from KP and
Newby would immediately lose racks
because of this mishap which would
eventually lead to their loss of the
second game at this point Newby could
simply not stop liquids momentum losing
their chance at the aegis of champions
during the 2015 Asia Championships team
secret and cloud 9 were locked in a
heated playoff affair but as cloud 9
looked to be taking control things got a
bit awkward to say the least
essentially c9 collectively forgot that
they didn't have any teleports available
and secret were happy to sneak up behind
them and decimate their barracks before
the boys and blue could react there's
just nothing more to say about this one
going for a pastries I've it is survived
the only side now it switches over to
Kura who goes set this up secret of
pushing top they're also pushing bottom
what's the movie the scenic overthrow
they put it back off they're not even
going for the racks right now
where are the teepees I thought that
does not have a TP and B also I don't
think as a teepee no one has CP there is
no millious game to something going over
this road oh no it's a catastrophe the
cloud 9 he comes as forest well they
just running back they're running for
dear life they've got to protect the
base I'm chasing that pup the ultimate
there's no cliff avail he dies in the
mountain when he's got ages he can't
even fight back and TP hard they're just
gonna get the throne over this holy [ __ ]
cloud 9
lost game too I can't believe it
what just happened
here it is the bummer of the fall king
stinker the worst dota2 miss play of all
time and well I bet you probably saw
this one coming
it's KY x wise Aegis deny of the
international three in 2013 in Game
three of the lower bracket final Navi
was facing off against orange and while
orange was rolling over them they were
able to snowball some early teamfights
and set up to take roshan then it
happened
KY XY deny the aegis of immortals from
mushi and Navi saw an opportunity to
pounce
we see rosh I'm just RNG gaming on mushi
bring him down to almost half life no
way to stop it I may as well just go
back into that William to continue to
farm up and then just deal with this
agus when it comes out should be on the
hand too pushy and make your hands of
Windrunner yeah then I want to deny that
they failed oh oh we see a lot of rare
sping in and outs for witnessing Nile
Venegas that's not really what you want
to do gateway XY
that they are not too happy right now of
course at this point when you have
disadvantage you don't really kill
Roshan for the experience and gold you
kill it for that ages it must be like it
like a tack moving there or something
like that it's definitely an accent it
is first deathly accident this isn't the
ultimate diss up against Nami say we
don't need no bit done excellence in
what was the biggest mistake in Ti
history the Europeans managed a crazy
come-from-behind victory guys we produce
great content just like this each and
every week so if you're not subscribed
to the channel already well that's the
real missplay thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]